Where can I report animal abuse?
There are several instances to denounce animal abuse in Mexico
City Some options include the environmental and territorial
planning attorney's office through its website or on its telephone line,
the complaint service unit of the Secretariat of
Citizen Security at PROFEPA by calling the toll-free
number or sending an email to complaints at PROFEPA point.
Gov point.
MX Any of these units can be used to report animal abuse in
Mexico City and receive appropriate assistance in taking action.
I hope this information has been of interest to you in case you
perceive a situation of animal abuse in Mexico City Remember that
you can report no more animal abuse Please contact attorney point.
Com for more information on legal situations Just enter search and contact.